30 seconds to on
air okay and you are just here good
night said father
back now an extraordinary story about a
young man who many years ago visited
Prague what he found there with
thousands of refugees at the mercy of
Hitler's imminent
Invasion do you have the think about the
children and what happened to
them I bet you got some
stories that's really not about
me we are working to evacuate these
children by trained to Safety in Britain
why are you doing this Mr Winton because
I may be able to do something about it I
must go
now
Nikki you must know we cannot save them
all you have to forgive yourself
that I'm stared sir I have to finish
it we cannot let these people
down it is incredible what you
achieved we're doing as much as we
can you have a lot of faith in ordinary
people because I'm an ordinary
person save one life save the world
forgive me but how many children are we
speaking
about can I ask is there anyone in the
audience tonight who owes their life to
Nicholas
[Music]
Winton